[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELIE BURZSTEIN: If you
are new to our session
on cutting edge TensorFlow,
my name is Elie.
And today with Josh,
Mike, and Sophien,
we have four exciting
projects for you.
First, I will talk
about Keras Tuner.
Then, Josh will talk about
probability programming.
Next, Mike will talk
about TF-Ranking.
And finally, Sofien will show
you how to use TensorFlow.
Graphics
Let me start by telling you
about Keras Tuner, which
is a framework we initially
developed internally
to bring new [INAUDIBLE]
model to faster to production.
Before getting started,
let me ask you a question.
How many of you have ever spent
time optimizing your model
performances.
Right, I see quite
a few hands raised.
This is not surprising
because getting the best model
performances is not easy.
Getting the best
model performances
is hard because there are many
parameters such as the learning
rate, the batch size,
and the number of layers
which influence the
model performances.
Moreover, those parameters
are interdependent,
which make finding the
optimal combinations by hand
very challenging.
This is why we rely hypertuning
to automatically find
the best combinations.
However so far,
hypertuning have been
known to be not easy to use.
So if hypertuning
is essential to get
the optimal performances,
this begs the question,
can we make it easy
as one, two, three?
And the answer is yes.
This is why today I
am happy to introduce
to Keras Tuner which is a tuning
framework made for humans.
Keras Tuner is a
tuning framework
designed to make the
life of AI practitioner
as easy as possible.
It also helps hypertuner
algorithm creators and model
designers by providing them with
a clean and easy to use API.
For AI practitioner,
which is most of us,
Keras Tuner makes
moving from a base model
to a hypertuned
model quick and easy.
Let me show you how this is
done by converting a basic MNIST
model to a hypertuned one.
We will only have to
change a few lines of code.
Here's our basic MNIST
model that is a TensorFlow
Keras controlled API.
This is something I'm sure
all of you have seen already.
As you can set on the side,
all parameter are fixed.
For example, our learning
rate is set to 0.001.
So let's transition it
to a hypertunable model
in three steps.
First, we wrap up our
model in a function.
Second, we define
hyper-parameter ranges
for the parameter that we
would like to optimize.
Here for example, we're going
to optimize the learning
rate which is one of the
most important parameters
to hypertune.
Finally as the last step, we
replace our fixed parameters
with our hyper-parameter range.
And we're done.
Our model is ready
to be hypertuned.
This is as easy.
Besides offering an
intuitive API Keras Tuner,
we'll also provide you with
state of the art hypertuning
algorithm, tuneable
architectures which
are ready to go, and an
automatic experimental
recording which make it easy
for you to analyze, share,
and reproduce your results.
Originally, I started developing
Keras Tuner to quickly try it
on new models for
[INAUDIBLE] purposes
including the one we
developed to protect Gmail
against malware and phishing.
Band detection is one
of the core building
block we need to protect your
inbox against phishing email
that impersonates
the brand you love.
This is why today, our
[INAUDIBLE] example
would be to show you how
to build a simple and yet
accurate brand logo classifier
as logo identification is
one of the critical components
to detect brand spoofing email.
The first thing we need to
do is to load our dataset.
In that example, we
have about the 150 icons
from various brands, including
the ones displayed on the side.
We also need to
set a few variables
such as batch size and
the number of icons
we're going to use [INAUDIBLE].
Next, our data set is
very small so we'll
rely on data augmentation to
create enough training data.
This slide shows you a few
examples of the augmented icons
we're going to feed to
the classifier as training
input, the output
being the brand names.
We are going to save the real
icon as our validation dataset
to make sure that our
classifier degenerates well.
To establish a
baseline, let's first
train a ResNet101v2 which is
one of the most common and well
known model architectures.
As you can see on the
[INAUDIBLE] graph,
our model did converge but
the actuality on real icon
is not great.
We barely reached 79% accuracy.
And it's also quite big
with 44 million parameters.
Well, that's OK.
We can use Keras Tuner to
find a better model which
is smaller and more accurate.
So to do that, the first
thing we need to do
is to create, as the MNIST
model a model function and input
TunableResNet.
TunableResNet is a
tunable version of ResNet
that we will provide
with Keras Tuner
as one of the architectures
which are ready to tune.
Next, you add a few
layers on top of it
and combine the model.
Then well, we
initialize the tuner
and we give it $500 to spend on
tuning to find the best model.
And we ask it to maximize
evaluation accuracy.
Finally, we have to
launch the tuning
and wait for the results.
So did it work?
Well, yes it did.
Actually, Keras Tuner
found a way better model.
Our new model have
now 100% accuracy
and only takes 24
million parameters.
So we get a faster
and more accurate
model thanks to hypertuning.
Keras Tuner works with
many of the tools you love,
including TensorBoard,
Colab, and BigQuery,
and many more to come.
One more thing.
Hypertuning takes a long
time so to make everything
more convenient, we
will be releasing
alongside with Keras Tuner an
optional cloud service that
will allow you to monitor
your tuning on the go
whether it's from your
phone or from your laptop.
Here is a screenshot of an early
version of the mobile dashboard
to give you a sense
of what to expect.
So the design is not
final, but the UI
will show you how long before
you're tuning complete,
as well as offer you a visual
summary of the model trained
so far so you can know
how your tuning is going.
Thank you for attending today.
We are really excited
about Keras Tuner.
And you can sign up today
for the early access program
by heading to
g.co/research/kerastunereap.
[APPLAUSE]
Josh is now going to talk
about [INAUDIBLE] programming
and TensorFlow.
JOSH DILLON: OK.
Hi, I'm Josh.
And today, we'll be
talking about everyone's
favorite topic-- probability.
So let's just start
with a simple example.
So suppose we're trying to
predict these blue dots--
that is, the Y-coordinate
from the X-coordinate.
And Keras makes this
pretty easy to do.
As you can see here, we
have a dense neural network
with one hidden layer
outputting one float.
And that float is the
predicted Y-coordinate.
And we've chosen mean squared
error as a loss, which
is a good default choice.
But the question is, how do we
make our loss function better?
What does a better loss
function look like?
And how would we even know?
How would we evaluate
the fit of this model?
And so we would like to be able
to specify the negative log
likelihood as a
generic loss, but then
encode the distributional
assumptions in the model.
And furthermore, if
we're doing that,
then wouldn't it
be nice to get back
an object for which
we can query--
ask for the mean, the variance,
the entropy, et cetera.
And the answer is
we can do this.
Using a TensorFlow probability
distribution layer,
we can say that we want the
neural network to output
a distribution, basically.
And the way this
works is as you can
see, the second to the last
layer here outputs one float.
That float is interpreted
as the location or mean
of a normal distribution.
And that's how we can
implement linear regression.
And as you see here, the fit
is this sort of red line.
But what's cool
is, we're actually
outputting a distribution.
Right?
So you can take
this output and just
ask for the entropy or the
variance of the prediction.
So that's nice.
But now that we've
done this, there's
sort of something that
looks a little fishy here.
We're learning the mean, but
not the standard deviation.
It seems like maybe
a missed opportunity
to improve our model.
And that missed opportunity
is now self-evident
that we're learning a
distribution directly-- sort
of an idea that was hidden
in what was otherwise
the mean square error.
So to learn standard
deviation, it's just
another one or two line change.
Instead of outputting one
float, we now output two.
One is interpreted as the
mean as before, the location.
The other when passed
through a soft plus function,
is now interpreted as
the standard deviation.
And what you see is
we're now able to get
this sort of green
line and the red lime--
green being the
standard deviation,
red being the mean
fit from before.
As you can see, sort
of the green line
diverges as X increases.
And so that suggests
that our data--
the variability of
Y, actually-- changes
as a function of
X. Statisticians
call this heteroskedasticity.
But I'd just like to think of
it as learning known unknowns.
There was variability
present in our data.
And because we took a
more probabilistic view
of our model, it was pretty easy
to see how we should fit that.
So that seems pretty cool.
But I guess the question
is, now that we're
thinking about sort
of known unknowns
or aleatoric uncertainty,
what about unknown unknowns?
Do we even have enough data
to accurately make the claim
that this is the
standard deviation
and mean of this
regression problem?
And if we don't, how
might we get there?
And the answer is--
or an answer-- is
to be Bayesian.
Rather than to just fit
the weights, if instead we
think about weights is being
drawn from a distribution
and try to find what might
be the best posterior
distribution, then
we can actually
capture some degree
of unknown unknowns.
That is, keeping track
of how much evidence
we have or don't have to make
the prediction we want to make.
So in practice, this
boils down to something
that looks a lot like
learning an ensemble.
As you can see here,
there are numerous random
draws each
corresponding to a line.
But what's cool is
computationally,
we only pay a small additional
overhead for fitting
what is otherwise an
infinite number of models.
So that seems pretty cool.
But we seem to have lost
the aleatoric uncertainty--
the known unknowns.
And so can we get it back?
Yes.
Since all of this
is modular, you
can simply specify whatever
assumptions you want to make.
We're back to fitting
the standard deviation
by outputting two floats
from that penultimate layer.
And yet, each of those
dense variational layers
are sort of representing
an infinite number
of possible weights.
So now, we're starting to get
a fairly sophisticated model.
And to get here, all
we had to do is just
keep swapping out one sort of
cross layer for a probability
layer, output a
distribution, change weights
to be distributions.
So that's pretty
powerful and yet,
a sequence of simple changes.
Of course now we can
ask, what if we are not
even sure that a line is the
right thing to be fitting here?
What if we actually want
to think about the loss
function itself as
being a random variable?
In this framework where we're
able to just encode ideas
as random variables,
everything's on the table,
right?
So what would that look like?
And how would we do it?
The answer in this case is to
use the variational Gaussian
process layer.
And from that, we conclude the
data wasn't even linear at all.
In fact, it had this dampened
sinusoidal structure.
So no wonder we're having
a hard time fitting it.
We were using-- in
some sense-- just
fundamentally the wrong model.
And the way we got here
is by just questioning
every assumption in
our model, but not
having to think about
sort of the relationship
between different
losses which otherwise
might seem arbitrary--
rather, a sequence of modeling
assumptions.
So how was this all so easy?
With TensorFlow probability.
TensorFlow probability
is a toolbox
for probabilistic modeling built
on or in or using TensorFlow.
Statisticians and
data scientists
will be able to write
and launch the same model
and ML researchers
and practitioners
can make predictions
with uncertainty.
You saw just a small part of the
overall TensorFlow probability
tool box.
More broadly, it offers
tools for building models
and for doing inference
within those models.
On the model building
side, the lowest level
of most basic abstraction
is distributions.
You saw the normal distribution.
It's exactly what you think--
gamma, exponential, et cetera.
These are sort of the
building blocks of your model.
And they're all built to take
advantage of vector processing
hardware, and in a way
that sort of automatically
takes advantage of it.
Next, we have bijectors.
This is a module for
transforming distributions
to bestill other distributions.
Defeomorphisms is the $10
word to describe these.
And they can range from a simple
sort of exponential logarithm
transform to more
complicated transforms
that combined neural nets
with the defeomorphism-- so
for example, [INAUDIBLE]
regressive flows, real MVP.
Fairly exotic neural densities
can be built using bijectors.
You saw layers-- a
few examples of those.
We also have a number of
losses for making Monte Carlo
approximations.
And joint distribution
is an abstraction
for combining multiple
random variables as one.
On the inference side of the
fence we have Markov chain
Monte Carlo-- no probabilistic
modeling toolbox would be
complete without it--
within which have
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
and a number of other
transition kernels
which generally take
advantage of TensorFlow's
automatic differentiation
capability.
We also tools for
variation inference,
which turns inference into
an optimization problem.
And finally, we have
additional optimizers
that are useful for
probabilistic models--
for example, quasi
second order methods
like BFGS as well
as methods that
don't use the gradient
for cases where that's
computationally prohibitive.
So TensorFlow
probability is widely
used within alphabet, including
Google Brain and DeepMind.
It also is used externally.
One of the earliest
adopters is Baker Hughes GE.
And they use TFP to
basically treat models
as random variables for
purpose of detecting anomalies.
So one problem that they're
particularly interested in
is detecting when jet
engines will fail.
And luckily, their
dataset doesn't
have failing jet engines.
That would be a terrible thing.
And so we have to be Bayesian
and sort of infer the evidence
that we don't have.
So using TensorFlow
probability and TensorFlow,
they're able to process an
enormous amount of data--
six terabytes.
They are able to explore
over 250,000 different model
architectures and
to great profit,
seeing a 50% reduction
in false positives
and a 200% reduction
in false negatives.
And this sort TensorFlow graph
represents their pipeline--
the orange boxes you see
here-- heavily use TensorFlow
probability to, as I said, treat
the model as a random variable.
So the question I
want to leave you with
is, who will be the
next success story?
TensorFlow probability is an
open source Python library
built using
TensorFlow, which makes
it easy to combine deep learning
and probabilistic models
on modern hardware.
You can pip install
it right now.
Learn more at
TensorFlow.org/probability
or shoot us an email.
If you're interested also
in learning more about
Bayesian techniques
or just TensorFlow,
TensorFlow probability, Google
Bayesian Methods for hackers--
the online version
of this book, we
rewrote to use
TensorFlow probability.
I think it's a great way to get
started if you're interested.
On our GitHub
repository, you'll also
find numerous
examples, including
the one you saw today.
Thank you.
And with that, Mike will
talk to you TF ranking.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL BENDERSKY:
Thank you Josh.
Hello everyone.
My name is Michael.
And today, I'll be talking about
TF ranking, a scalable learning
to rank library for TensorFlow.
So first of, I'll
start by defining
what is learning
to rank, which is
the problem we're trying to
solve with TensorFlow ranking.
Imagine you have
a list of items.
And here, the green shades
indicate the relevance levels
of these items.
The goal of learning to rank is
to learn a scoring function, F,
such as to take a
list of these items
and produces an optimal
ordering of these items
in their order of the relevance.
So the greenest item
would be at the top.
This seems like a
very abstract problem.
However, it has a lot of
practical applications.
In search, we rank documents
in response to user queries.
In recommendation systems, we
rank items for a given user.
In dialogue systems, we rank
responses for a user request.
And similar in questioning
answering systems,
we rank answers in
response to user questions.
One very common
application of ranking
that requires massive
amount of data
is a click position
optimization.
In this setting, the function,
F, takes in as an input
a rank list where
we have some clicks
on the items in the list.
The perfect ranking
in this case assumes
that the click
documents should be
placed at the top of the list.
Later in this talk, I will show
an example of this application.
OK, so let's talk about
TensorFlow ranking or TF
ranking for short.
It was first announced on
Google AI blog on December 2018.
And it's a first
open source library
that does learning to rank
at scale with deep learning
approaches.
It's actively maintained and
developed by the TF franking
team here at Google.
And it is fully compatible with
entire TensorFlow ecosystem,
including tools like TensorBoard
and TensorFlow Serving.
One interesting
problem which we're
trying to solve
with TF ranking is
that unlike classification
or regression metrics,
ranking metrics are
usually non-convexed.
In fact, most [INAUDIBLE]
ranking metrics
are either
discontinuous or flat.
I'll give an example.
In this case, we
see a step function.
And the step here
indicates what happens
when we change the score
of the items in the list
and then there is a
rank swap that occurs.
When the score changes
and the swap occurs,
we are basically becoming
discontinuous in the function
space.
The rest of the function
is flat because we do not
change the ordering of the
items when we change the scores.
These types of function are
very difficult or impossible
to directly optimize
[INAUDIBLE] gradient descent.
Due to that, researchers
in learning to rank
have been developing different
types of loss functions.
One common loss function is
the point [INAUDIBLE] loss,
where we basically take
as an input each item
and assign to them a probability
of them being relevant.
This is very similar to a
classification or regression
case, but completely
ignores the relationship
between the different
items in the list.
So pairwise ranking
losses were proposed.
These use pair comparisons
to order the list.
So instead of learning a
probability for each item,
we learn probabilities
of one item
being preferable
to another item.
Again, this does not
capture the entire list--
just pairs.
So list-wise ranking
losses were proposed
instead in the which function,
F, takes one item at a time
but tries to optimize the
ordering of the entire list
producing pi star, which
is the optimal permutation
on the items.
One new development we
propose in TensorFlow ranking
is this idea of
multi-item scoring.
So unlike in the previous slide
where the function, F, takes
one item at a time, in
multi-item scoring scenario,
the function, F, takes
all the item in at times
and produces the optimal
ordering, pi star.
This is really important for
complex interdependent inputs
and allows to use the
context of other items
to make better
ranking decisions.
One important thing
to note is that we
support many, many metrics
in TensorFlow ranking.
So we support standard metrics
like (N)DCG, ARP, Precision@K,
and others.
But it's also very easy
to add your own metrics
to TensorFlow ranking.
And once you have the
metric you want to optimize
and you use TensorBoard,
you can easily visualize it
while you train your model.
So you can see how your (N)DCG
or other metric progresses
as you model trains
across the apex.
So let me jump
into describing how
you can develop your own state
of the art ready to deploy
learning to rank model in four
simple steps using TensorFlow
ranking.
First, you specify
a scoring function.
Then you specify the metrics
that you want to optimize for.
Then you specify
your loss function.
And finally, you build
your ranking estimate
using all of these
three previous steps.
Here how it looks in code.
First, we define the
scoring function.
And here, we use three hidden
layer scoring function.
Then we specify the
evaluation metrics.
In this case, we
use (N)DCG metrics
and we use (N)DCG at top ranks.
Finally, we need to
specify the lowest function
and the ranking estimator.
Here, we propose using a ranking
head with a soft max loss.
However, note the
soft max loss can
be easily replaced by any other
loss supported by TF ranking.
So it's very easy to
switch between losses
by simply replacing this
parameter to something else.
And finally, you build
the ranking estimator.
Interesting thing about
the ranking estimator,
it takes into as a
parameter this group size.
So this group
size, if you set it
to something that
is greater than one,
you're essentially enabling
the multi-item scoring
I was referring to before.
If you set up to
one, you fall back
to using standard learn
to rank approaches
with single item scoring.
So let's say in less
than 50 lines of code,
you're already build your
own learning to rank model.
And now, you're ready to
train it on your train data.
OK, I'm just going
to finish this
by giving an example of how
TF ranking works in practice.
And I'm going to go back to
the click position optimization
problem I posed before.
To remind you, in this case,
the perfect ranking when
we take in as an
input a click data,
we produce a rank
list [INAUDIBLE]
the clicked items will be
at the top of the list.
We're using an
internal dataset here
of around one billion
query document pairs.
And for each query
document pair,
we extract the following--
some numerical features
that we associate
with this query document
pair, the query and document
text, the position at which
document was displayed.
And as labels, we use click
or no-click information
about this particular
document for this query.
Here, we compared the
performance of your TF ranking
to lambdaMART which is a
state of the art learning
to rank approach.
It's interesting to know that
when you compare TF ranking
using numerical
features only, it
is comparable to
lambdaMART on this dataset.
However, the more
interesting thing
is that when we add
text as features--
we achieve big improvements,
especially when
using TF ranking in
ensemble with lambdaMART.
On this dataset, we
achieve over 3% gain
when we're adding sparce
textual features into the model
and ensembling lambdaMART
and TF ranking, which
is a very significant
improvement
for a dataset this size.
All right, so I
hope I got you all
excited about using TF ranking.
What should you do next?
So you can go and read
our paper and archive
about TF ranking and
all the work that
went into developing it.
Then, check out our
GitHub repository.
It has all information
about TF ranking.
And install TF ranking from
there by using pip install.
You can run through
a simple call
that we have on our
GitHub repository.
And that's it.
You're ready to start
building your next learn
to rank application.
I would like to extend
huge thanks to everyone
on the TF ranking team who
made this project possible.
And next up is Sofien to talk
about TensorFlow graphics.
[APPLAUSE]
SOFIEN BOUAZIZ: Thanks Mike.
Thanks.
Hi everyone.
My name is Sofien.
And today, I'm proud to
announce the first release
of a new library called
TensorFlow graphics.
But before getting
any further, let's
start from the very beginning
and define computer graphics.
Computer graphics is a
subfield of computer science
which studies methods for
digitally synthesizing
and manipulating visual content.
Most of you have been
exposed to computer graphics
through movies and
video games where
amazingly beautiful
synthetic scenes are
rendered photo-realistically.
And this is thanks
to many advances
in the computer graphics field.
To give you some
perspective, this
is what first computer
graphics in 1958
with the first interactive
game called Tennis for Two.
As can see, we have
come a long way.
To generate
beautiful renderings,
a computer graphics system
needs [INAUDIBLE] input
in description.
These often include
transformations
which explain how the
objects are placed in space,
camera models which describe
from which point of view
the scene needs to be rendered,
light and matter models--
defining object appearances--
and finally [INAUDIBLE]
geometry.
These parameters are then
interpreted by renderer
to generate a beautiful image.
Now in comparison to
computer graphics,
computer vision is
concerned with the theory
beyond artificial system
that extract information
from images.
So we can see computer
vision and computer graphics
as a duality.
A computer vision system
would start from an image
and try to automatically
extract a scene description,
estimating the three dimensional
position and orientation
of objects, understanding
the material properties,
or just recognizing these
objects based on their 3D
geometry.
Answering these type of
questions about the three
dimensional world is
fundamental for many machine
learning applications.
A good example are autonomous
vehicles and robots
that need to reason about
three dimensional objects
and their relationship in space.
However, to train a
machine learning system
solving this complex 3D vision
tasks, a large quantity of data
is needed.
Labeling data being a
complex and costly process,
it is important to a mechanism
to design machine learning
systems that can reason about
the three dimensional world
while being trained
without much supervision.
So combining computer
vision and computer graphics
provides a unique
opportunity to leverage
a vast amount of readily
available unlabeled data.
This can be done by a
technique called analysis
by synthesis where the
vision system extracts
the scene parameters
and the graphic system
renders back an
image based on them.
If the rendering
matches original image,
the vision system
has done a great job
at extracting the
correct scene parameters.
In this setup, computer
vision and computer graphics
go hand in hand,
forming a single machine
learning system similar
to a neutron coder.
TensorFlow graphics
is being developed
to solve this type of problems.
And we are aiming at providing
a set of differential graphics
layer that can be used in your
[INAUDIBLE] machine learning
models.
So for the sake of time, we'll
focus on four useful components
that can be included into
a deep learning models
to solve these interesting
three division tasks.
So during the next slide,
you will see a QR code
like this one.
If you are interested,
use your smartphone.
Point your smartphone
toward the slide
and you will be directed to
the [INAUDIBLE] free resources.
So get ready.
These QR codes are going to
come back in later slides.
OK so now now,
let's jump right in
and see how 3D transformation
can be expressed
using TensorFlow graphics.
One basic building block
for manipulating 3D shapes
are 3D rotations.
In TensorFlow graphics,
we are providing
a set of classical
representation,
also implemented function,
to convert between them.
One easy way to
represent rotation
is by using an axis and an
angle defining our major object
to rotate around this axis.
This can be easily expressed
in TensorFlow graphics
using our transformation
module where in this code,
we first loads the
vertices of the cube.
We then define the axis
of rotation and the angle.
And finally, we apply
the transformation
to the cube using
rotate function
of the axis single module.
Now that we have
seen how easy it
is to express rotation
in TensorFlow graphics,
let's move on to camera models.
Camera models play
a fundamental role
in computer vision as the
great [? influencer ?]
of appearances of three
dimensional objects that
are projected onto
the camera plane.
As you can see in
this slide, the cube
appears to be
scanning up and down.
But it is actually the camera
focal lens that is changing.
Currently in
TensorFlow graphics,
we propose two type of cameras--
an autographic and a
perspective camera model.
So let's see how the
perspective camera model works.
One common operation
used with a camera model
is to project a set of 3D
points onto a 2D camera plane.
And this can also be expressed
easily with TensorFlow graphics
where in this code
similarly we first
load the vertices of the cube.
We then define the intrinsic
parameters of the camera
and this allows us to map
the 3D vertices of the cube
to 2D using the project function
of the perspective camera
module.
So far, we
[INAUDIBLE] 3D objects
and optimize them to 2D.
But what about the
appearances of these objects?
In TensorFlow graphics, we're
providing a few simple material
models are going to render
3D objects using TensorFlow.
To be slightly more concrete,
these material models
define how the light reflects
off the surface of an object.
So given an incoming light
action, how much of the light
will bounce off the surface
toward a particular outgoing
direction?
So the input parameter needed
for the material model are
the surface [INAUDIBLE]
of the 3D object,
the incoming light direction,
the outgoing direction--
for example, pointing
toward the camera--
and the material parameter-- in
this case, color and shininess.
Given all these inputs,
TensorFlow graphics
can evaluate how much
light is reflected
off the surface and the
outgoing direction which allows
us to shape the camera pixel.
And in case this
is all new for you,
we provide a collab
where you would
be able to see this
concept in more details.
OK so now that we have seen
some of [INAUDIBLE] graphics
functionality that TensorFlow
graphics introduces,
let's talk about
geometry-- and especially
how TensorFlow graphics can
help in expressing convolution,
on measures, and point clouds.
Image convolution is
a basic building block
of deep learning.
They have been extensively
used in many learning tasks
such as image classification.
The nice parts of
dealing with images
is that they are represented
by a uniform grid, which
makes convolution
[INAUDIBLE] easy to implement
and consequently, convolution
[INAUDIBLE] networks.
In TensorFlow image convolution
are readily available.
However, things become
a bit more complicated
when dealing with three
dimensional objects which
are often defined
as measures in point
clouds and are not
represented as a uniform grid.
This makes convolution
hard to implement,
and also now networks
based on them.
In recent years sensor giving
three dimensional point clouds
are becoming part
of everyday life
from smartphone def sensors to
self-driving car [? radars. ?]
It is therefore
important to open
source such functionalities
for developers and researchers
to be able to
efficiently use 3D data
and extract
information from them.
In TensorFlow graphics,
we propose a set
of graph convolution
operators which
can almost be used as a
drop in with placement
after convolution.
So in this code, we
first must load the mesh
in the form of vertices
and connectivity.
We then apply one of the
graph convolution operator
that TensorFlow
graphics provide.
It is also important to
note that we are providing
the equivalent Keras layers.
And finally, the
convolution layer
can be followed by a classic
[INAUDIBLE],, all the layers.
To demonstrate how
this can be used
inside a more complex
neural networks,
we also provide a
collab doing three
dimensional semantic human part
segmentation as an example.
So during the few
slides, we are seeing
a small set of the TensorFlow
graphics functionalities.
And the good news is that we
are providing many more of them.
And we will also add more
of these functionalities
in the near future.
But there's also one more thing.
We are glad to announce
a new TensorFlow
plug-in allowing measures and
point cloud visualization.
And I believe that
this plug-in will
be amazingly useful for
developers and researchers that
want to use TensorFlow to
analyze three dimensional data.
So get started today.
We provide the pre-package.
And installing the library
is as easy as doing pip
install tensorflow-graphics.
In case you are really excited
about TensorFlow graphics,
we have a GitHub
page from which you
can pull our latest features.
We are also providing a
comprehensive API documentation
and multiple collabs from
which you can learn about some
of the functionalities
we are providing.
Before ending the
talk, I would like
to thank people that
have really contributed
to make this project happen.
Thank you very much, everyone.
I hope you enjoyed
this presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]